Washington DC Mayor Muriel Bowser
mandating new rules and closures for
restaurants and bars and the move did
not sit well with Tom Johnson Managing
Partner of the Hill Restaurant Group he
has several restaurants here Johnson
said on Facebook initially we will not
bow down to pressure from the mayor's
office or any group for that matter who
covertly is attempting to shut us down
we fully support our employees and our
patrons well the mayor responded by
saying the group must comply and Johnson
responded telling the Washington Post
quote I have to start letting people go
I don't have the wherewithal to pay them
he said it's literally going to put me
out of business
I'm going to go bankrupt let's talk
about it with dr. Steve Weinberg former
medical director of the Peace Corps
doctor good to have you with us tonight
Thank You Shannon good to be here
all right now let me ask you because
this is not your first rodeo you were
around during the Bush administration
when the SARS epidemic hit what can you
tell us as way of context for government
response in the midst of all these
things we see rolling out well this is
an incredible response Shin and SARS was
fairly limited you know it lasted
basically a few months and it was over
we had to move our Peace Corps
volunteers out of China for a couple of
months they went back in this is
worldwide it's nowhere near the end is
here dr. Fauci said today it's going to
get worse before it's going to get
better and the the government response
so far is incredible doctor foul Chi dr.
Burks or two folks have worked with and
they are not just the best in Washington
DC but they're the best in the country
in the world in infectious disease in
virology so I have great confidence that
they're going to get this under control
and and we're gonna be able to handle
this and get through it on the other
side is a stronger country I want to
play something that the President had to
say today as part of the daily presser
that we've had just about every day
here's what he said if they're able to
get ventilators respirators if they're
able to get certain things without
having to go through the the longer
process of federal government we have
stockpiles now or we're ordering
tremendous numbers of ventilators
respirators masks and they're ordered
and they're coming but if they can if
they can get them directly it's always
going to be faster
she'd get them directly if they need
them so there was a lengthy phone call
today between a number of Governors and
the president and there was this talk
about whether or not he was telling
States hey you're on your own to get
ventilators apparently that's not what
he said but he did tell them listen if
you have a more direct way to get them
instead of going through the federal
government that may be your best option
what's your sense of whether we're
prepared on that front or could be in
time well I hope we are that my best
census we are the the idea is the the
relative draconian measures were put
into place last night
CDC today by the by the task force if we
can get this controlled in the next few
weeks we're not going to need all those
ventilators that we're hypothesizing
they're only for the most critical
people the elderly that have severe
pulmonary problems and I think right now
we're in pretty good shape we should
have enough we'll have enough ICU beds
and I think we can take care of the
population that needs it if we can stop
the progression of this disease do you
think quickly at this moment that we
have done enough in this distancing and
closing things down to get a week or two
ahead of where maybe Italy would be at
this same point when we get to their
timeline I think we'll do a lot better
than Italy yes I do Shanna we may have
to go farther I have great confidence in
the American people I think they're
gonna listen to the the task force what
they said today the social distancing
distancing is is very valuable closing
lots of things down is very valuable as
an example and I don't necessarily think
this is 100% accurate but China if you
look at their data they have a CDC like
ours and they published some data in the
in the JAMA just recently just in the
last few days and they when they closed
down Wuhan and where they they closed
everything down they stopped the
progression of this disease within a
week I gotta stop you there but we know
you were coming back next hour we don't
wanna get cut off so dr. Weinberg thank
you for being in our extended coverage
thank you so much we'll see you next
hour Thank You Shannon